hey did you check out the new Indiana
Jones trailer oh no I actually haven't
even seen the first one whoa what you
haven't seen India in a freaking Jones
now it just slipped through the cracks I
guess how it just slipped through the
cracks I guess
yeah I'm familiar with the music and you
know the general idea of it you should
die what how are you living like this
this is embarrassing dude sorry well we
need to watch it right now we're at work
and watch it tonight you know I don't
want to see it everyone gets weird when
I say I haven't seen it rightfully so I
don't feel like seeing it you have no
respect for Cinema I think that's the
problem you need to let this go I mean
you can lead a fish to the river but you
can't take a horse to out of the river
to the pond
to drink the water what it's all right I
forgive you thanks sorry I got mad it's
just you're nice one day and then crazy
the next it's like I work with Gollum
who Gollum I'm not sure what that okay